let's get into the mailbag first
question from may dear michael
i am nearly 30 and have strong catholic
beliefs
i have always dated cradle catholics but
they were never really believers as i am
yeah sometimes you know they're
a little more just cultural about it
they don't really believe it
i believe in waiting until marriage for
sex which gets increasingly difficult
when trying to date the older i get
i met a great guy and i really thought
we were perfect for each other
and we had plans to get married and for
the future against what i
knew was right i slept with him and were
no longer together whoever i meet next i
would still want to wait until we are
married but i'm afraid i messed up
and another good man may reject me
because of my transgressions i feel lost
and hopeless that having a family may
never happen for me
do you have any theological perspective
or advice on how i handle any of this
thank you
yeah go to confession confess your sins
pray a rosary and you'll be fine
i don't i don't mean to be flippant
about it people make mistakes
especially that everyone makes that
mistake these days virtually everyone i
mean
you know we're in a culture that's
saturated by sex where we're told that
having sex before marriage
is essential to do and you're a weirdo
if you don't do it
and you know you you just have to
there's a lot of pressure i mean there
are actually circumstances here
that that i think do mitigate this sin a
little bit
but sure you did it it's wrong it is
wrong even though everyone does it even
though a lot of people do it
it's wrong and you feel sorry about it
move on you know
your redeemer lives your savior lives
there there is a way for your sins to be
forgiven your sins are forgiven
you'll be fine we live in a very broken
culture too so if you're worried that
everybody else is so perfect
and you're not perfect so you're never
going to find a husband
come on give me a break you'll be all
right these things happen
i'm sure i'm sure you'll meet a very
nice man by the way i'm nearly 30
these days i'm you know i'm 32. that's
like
young to get married according to the
culture i know that it's not in
traditional standards
i wish i had gotten married much younger
i'm sure you do too
but you you've also got to recognize
these kind of cultural realities
and give yourself a little bit of grace
a little bit of
a little bit of uh breathing room here
you know
now maybe if this last guy you dated was
a jerk maybe even wasn't a jerk
sounds like he was kind of a jerk but
let you know regardless
find a better guy the next time it's
okay breathe
your savior lives god forgives your sins
you can forgive yourself
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
[Music]
[Music]
podcasts